[Applaudissements]
écoutez moi tous
la musique car actuellement pendant la
pause on ne va pas se mentir jean michel
maire est allé aux toilettes donc ils
pensaient qu'on allait pas reprendre sur
lui c'était mal ne connaîtra donc là il
ne le sait pas et quand il va revenir
vous allez lui aimait croisière va
permis mais pendant ce temps là avec
qu'il arrive nous fait confiance on
démarre si vous le voulez bien
les tops et les flops néanmoins je
trouve que ça dure quand même depuis
longtemps au niveau des toilettes
s'inquiète il faudra lui demander si
c'était la petite la grosse convention
ces questions kepa sac et est ce que tu
t'es laver les mains non mais qu'est ce
qui vous a pris pourquoi ç'a duré si
longtemps mais non vie c'est à partir
d'un certain âge
bah non c'est pas vrai s'est pas lavé
les mains
est ce qu'on peut se dire
[Applaudissements]